Donald Trump had another one of these
very strange rallies over the weekend
this one was in West Virginia and at
this rally he said that he fell in love
with North Korean dictator Kim jong-un I
mean that that's the headline and it
seems like a joke it seems like it would
be a parody but it's real and I'm gonna
play the audio and video for you if you
are watching you'll notice an
extraordinarily sweaty and disheveled
Donald Trump and almost out of breath as
well explaining that he and Kim jong-un
have fallen in love those are his words
not mine
because of the beautiful letters I was
almost able to do it because of the
beautiful letters that Kim wrote to him
and I want to do more of an introduction
to set up the clip but there's really
nothing else to say let's take a look at
it and yes I agree the rhetoric was
unbelievably harsh at the beginning but
we have a very good relationship we were
going to war with North Korea if that
was what was going to happen we are
doing great that was a big big problem
and you know the interesting when I did
it and I was really being tough and so
was he I will go back and forth and then
we fell in love okay oh really
he wrote me beautiful letters and
they're great letters we fell in love
but you know what now they'll make just
like Donald Trump said they fell in love
how horrible how horrible is that so
unpresidential and I always tell you
it's so easy to be presidential but
instead of having 10,000 people outside
trying to get into this packed arena
we'd have about 200 people standing
right there it's not that it's
unpresidential that trump says he fell
in love with Kim jong-un it's that it's
extraordinarily disturbing particularly
when Trump seems unable to get along
with our allies like Germany France
Canada England and yet again it's
literally love letters with one of the
worst dictators in the world and it's
not about wishing that we continue to
have a bad relationship with other
countries it's it's never been about
that why is Trump so impressed with and
taken by literally enamored with people
like Kim jong-un and Iran and poo
and Duterte it's about Trump going to
the UN General Assembly last week and
praising Kim jong-un who remember
husband hasn't done a thing towards
fulfilling his promises from that bogus
Singapore summit and he says nothing
about actual Russian election
interference for example or anything
about praising our actual allies and
then putting aside the specifics of this
very strange comment about Kim jong-un
why is our president always cozying up
to dictators Bannen Steve Bannon
previously said that Trump gravitates
towards strong personalities which to me
sounds like those daddy issues that we
know Trump has had based on his
up-and-down relationship with his late
father it is amazing how we thought like
a year ago that Trump had said the
strangest most bizarre things he would
say that's nothing compared to stuff
like this like I fell in love we are in
love he is in love almost knocked over
my mug there we are we are now in love
and when I saw the headline Trump and
Kim jong-un fell in love I thought it's
got to be a misquote or an onion article
or something like that it's literally
what he said that they fall in love yeah
it's a long-distance relationship yes
what I'd call it
it's the kind of thing that lends itself
to so many jokes I mean like the Trump
Kim jong-un
meeting and everything that they had
since then all lends itself to jokes but
kim jong hoon is such a terrible
dictator and perpetrator of so many
human rights abuses this I feel like
maybe we shouldn't be joking about it
it's a lot more serious than this it is
serious and I would also say if you work
for the onion or SNL how do you take
this and satirize it this it's a self
parody to the enth degree it's totally
unimaginable